Roronoa Zoro is one of One Piece’s greatest
characters.
Hell, he’s one of manga’s greatest characters.
But why?
Maybe because he has the most unique and badass
sword fighting style in all of anime, or because
of that time he earned Mihawks respect with
his sense of honor, or the fact that he was
prepared to sacrifice that honor, his dream
and even his life for Luffy.
But the love for Zoro goes a lot deeper than
just his bad ass feats.
I mean you gotta love his personality
[clip of Zoro with shit personality]
All jokes aside, I’ve talked about why Zoro
is such an awesome character a lot on this
channel, but really you can boil it down to
just 3 things, that make him one of manga’s
greatest character.
BACKSTORY
(Backstory until he joins Luffy)
As you know, Zoro started out as a strong-willed
kid already determined to become the strongest
swordsman in the world, even before ever meeting
Kuina and their promise to each other.
We know that Zoro is somehow related to the
Shimotsuki clan from Wano, but ironically
grew up in Shimotsuki village, a colony of
former Wano citizens in the East Blue.
He trained at the Villages Dojo, where he
was able to beat anyone, but the dojo master’s
daughter Kuina.
After their promise to each other that one
of them would become the strongest swordsman
in the world, Kuina tragically died under
mysterious circumstances.
Her father says she fell down the stairs,
but it is strongly implied that she might
have taken her own life, because Kuina felt
that women were physically inferior to men
and could never make up for that difference.
This cemented Zoro’s dream even more and
he spent his entire youth training.
He became a bounty hunter to pay for his bills.
One day, in a village called shell town, he
saved a little girl from the marine captain’s
son helmepo.
In exchange for not being labeld a criminal
by the marines, Zoro agreed to be tied to
a pole in front of the marine’s headquarter
and not eat for a month.
A deal that the marines never intended to
uphold.
So, despite being a lone wolf, Zoro decided
to accept Luffy’s offer to join his crew.
And everything after that is history with
countless epic fights and moments for the
future strongest swordsman in the world.
PART I
But the love for Zoro goes a lot deeper than
just bad ass feats.
It’s the character’s personality that
makes him resonate with so many fans and make
him one of the most popular characters in
all of One Piece, sometimes even outranking
Luffy himself in that regard.
What are the attributes and values that best
define the Straw Hats’ Moss-Headed swordsman?
First and foremost is strength.
There’s no shortage of fans who speculate
that Zoro might be even stronger than Luffy
(though it helps that blades are one of Luffy’s
weaknesses).
Zoro is driven to become the world’s greatest
swordsman - a feat that will take immeasurable
strength.
Second is discipline.
There is no easy path or shortcut to the type
of strength that Zoro seeks.
While the rest of the crew “makes merry”
on the ship, Zoro is constantly working out,
lifting the biggest weights known to man.
He knows that he can only achieve his dream
through diligent training.
Third is honor.
Despite his ferocious power, he is morally
upright.
He will always make what he perceives to be
the honorable choice.
For instance, he refused to let Mihawk strike
his back and instead takes his defeat standing
upright instead of turning tail and running
away.
The final value that defines Zoro is altruism.
Even though, he has a singularly focused pursuit
of his goal, he is willing to lay down his
life for others.
Even his own dream, to become the world’s
greatest swordsman, is not his alone.
He fights for this dream just as much to honor
Kuina’s memory.
Our very first introduction to Zoro exemplified
these core values.
When Koby first told Luffy about the rumors,
we were introduced to a terrifying monster
- a bloodthirsty, superhuman pirate hunter.
But when we saw him in the stocks, he showed
great discipline and honor.
He went without food and water for days on
end and he did it for the sake of an innocent
family.
He did the honorable thing in allowing himself
to be imprisoned in exchange for the family’s
lives.
And when he asks Luffy to feed him the rice
balls that Helmeppo smashed on the ground,
it shows another honorable layer to his personality.
The fact that he was so strongly defined as
a character right from the beginning shows
how steadfast Zoro truly is in his convictions.
BRIDGE
To look even deeper into Zoro’s character,
though, we have to look beyond the values
What motifs and themes does Zoro portray?
And what real-world connections does Oda-Sensei
use in developing his character?
PART II
Themes
Religion among swordsmen
Many significant swordsmen in One Piece are
actually connected with one religion or another.
For instance, Shanks is connected with Nordic
mythology.
He’s the captain of a viking ship and his
one arm suggests parallels to the one-armed
Norse deity Tyr.
Dracule Mihawk, the current strongest swordsman
in the world, is connected with symbolism
from Christianity - or at least Gothic vampire
literature - which itself is linked directly
with Christianity.
His black blade, Yoru, makes his silhouette
appear as a giant Christian cross behind him.
Zoro, however, appears to have connections
to Buddhism.
This is mostly evident in his attack names,
such as his move “Crossing the Six Paths”
and Asura, a type of demigod within Buddhist
and Hindu religions.
Both of these religions in turn, were influenced
by Zoroastrianism, from which Zoro might even
derive his name.
Swords as a sign of respect
The swordsmen in One Piece seem to follow
a code of honor.
Swords themselves can even be seen as a sign
of respect.
When Zoro first encounters Mihawk, he jumps
at the chance to fulfill his goal.
If he defeats the Warlord, then he’ll become
the world’s greatest swordsman.
Mihawk, surely no stranger to such challenges,
thinks that Zoro is just another kid who thinks
he has what it takes to survive in the Grand
Line.
He doesn’t respect Zoro and therefore doesn’t
even use a sword against him.
He uses a tiny knife.
However, once Zoro demonstrates how honorable
he truly is by declaring that scars on the
back or a swordsman’s shame, Mihawk recognizes
Zoro as a worthy rival with genuine potential.
Out of respect, he uses Yoru to deal the finishing
blow of the duel.
During Zoro’s fight with King, we see what
a dishonorable swordsman looks like.
King doesn’t follow a similar moral code
to Zoro - instead he uses tricks such as his
hooked sword to try and disarm his opponent
rather than fight a genuine duel.
Also, any honorable swordsman would hit subscirbe
at this point of the video.
Bushido
It should come as no surprise that Zoro is
influenced by Samurai.
We’ve learned that he has heritage in Wano.
Shimotsuki Village in East Blue, where Zoro
was raised, was founded by samurai from Wano
who fled after Kaidou’s takeover.
Not only that, but Princess Vivi literally
calls Zoro “Mr. Bushido.”
For those who don’t know, “Bushido”
is another name for the samurai code or “way
of the samurai.”
Throughout the various periods of Japanese
history, Bushido has evolved with the time.
However, one popular summation of its tenets
comes from Nitobe Inazo of the Meiji Period.
The eight virtues he extolled were: righteousness,
courage, compassion, respect, honesty, honor,
loyalty, and self-control.
Obviously, these are all virtues that Roronoa
Zoro embodies.
Going by Bushido, he’s even more “samurai”
than the samurai of Wano.
BRIDGE
Now we’ll look at Zoro even more closely
- more than looking at him as an individual,
how does he fit into the story of One Piece?
What’s his role in the crew and what is
his overall story arc?
How does Zoro change throughout the story
and what does that teach us about his character?
PART III
Zoro serves two main roles in the Straw Hat
crew.
While technically not named as the first mate,
he clearly fits the part.
He’s Luffy’s right hand and has been there
since the beginning of Luffy’s adventure.
As the first mate, he’s not just a subordinate
to Luffy, though.
Instead he acts as Luffy’s counter balance.
He steps in as a leader when Luffy is incapacitated
and even holds the crew together in its times
of greatest turmoil.
He’s made such a name for himself as a noteworthy
pirate that, like Killer, he’s considered
part of the Supernovas despite not being a
captain.
Zoro’s official role on the crew is that
of the swordsman.
He’s one of the deadliest and most powerful
members of the crew, likely second only to
Luffy.
When there’s a battle to fight, Zoro is
the first to volunteer to cut down the opponent.
It’s no coincidence, either, that Zoro uses
blades.
One of Luffy’s biggest weaknesses is cutting
attacks, since he can resist blunt attacks
and even gunfire.
However, Zoro can go sword-to-sword with anyone
who could threaten to cut down his captain.
Zoro’s character arc is the story of an
individual overcoming a single central flaw.
And we’re not talk about his being directionally
challenged: his other fatal flaw.
Roronoa Zoro is a lone wolf.
In his quest to become the world’s greatest
swordsman, he’s all but given up friends
and camaraderie in exchange for an all-encompassing
focus on his goal.
He wants to achieve everything on his own.
Think about it - when Zoro gets lost from
the crew, this actually serves a crucial writing
purpose for Oda.
It’s not just a gag because often when the
crew gets divided into different groups, Zoro
ends up on his own.
In Sabaody, in Dressrosa, and Wano, just to
name a few, Zoro ends up in isolation from
the rest of the crew going on a solo adventure.
He perfectly captures the trope of the wandering
ronin.
However, Zoro’s greatest character development
throughout the series has been overcoming
this lone wolf persona.
He’s grown close to his crew to the point
where he’s even willing to sacrifice his
own dream for their sake.
Let’s take a look at Zoro’s growth throughout
each arc and show how he has grown as a character.
When Luffy first meets Zoro, his life is literally
on the line.
His unwavering sense of honor has put him
in danger at the hands of someone as dishonorable
as Helmeppo.
He agrees to go for weeks without food or
water strung up on a cross, not knowing that
the spoiled son of Axehand Morgan has no intention
of keeping his side of the bargain.
He laughs off Luffy’s request to join him
and become a pirate - he is a pirate hunter
after all - but after Luffy saves him from
execution he gains a newfound respect for
the captain.
Agreeing to join Luffy on his adventure seems
like just as good a path as any: after all,
the two both have impossibly ambitious dreams
- to become the pirate king and the world’s
greatest swordsman.
This call to grand adventure parallels when
Rayleigh joined Roger - he’s swayed by the
captain’s charisma and free spirit which
complements his own stoic and individual nature.
Even though Zoro walked his path alone, if
he hadn’t joined up with his captain, he
wouldn’t have survived.
The next monumental step in Zoro’s character
growth is on the Baratie, when he goes face
to face with Mihawk.
He’s utterly defeated, but the warlord still
sees something important in Zoro.
Even though he lacks power, he has the strength
of will to grow and become stronger.
The exchange between the two swordsmen actually
foreshadows many of Zoro’s later feats.
Mihawk defeats him with a tiny knife - much
like the knife Zoro uses at the beginning
of Wano to escape his captors.
He sees Mihawk slice a ship in half - a feat
Zoro is more than capable of after the timeskip.
And Mihawk even refers to Zoro as “a frog
in a well” - an idiom with a similar meaning
to the English “small fish in a big pond.”
Later in Fishman Island, Zoro would say the
same to Hyouzou, the overly confident greatest
swordsman of Fishman Island.
In Arlong Park and Loguetown, Zoro comes to
respect Luffy more.
When he confronts Arlong, he sees how far
Luffy is willing to go for someone he considers
his nakama.
In Loguetown, he sees Luffy’s fearlessness
in the face of death and how he’s willing
to die if it means he’s working toward achieving
his dream.
In Water 7, we really see Zoro step into the
role of the first mate.
When Luffy and Usopp fight over the fate of
the Going Merry, the rest of the crew are
devastated.
Zoro, however, is the glue that keeps them
together.
His coolheaded, stoic demeanor are crucial
in a situation like this.
When everyone’s emotions are high, he occupies
the difficult position and does what must
be done to maintain the sanctity of the Straw
Hats.
He understands how difficult this conflict
is for Luffy, but even as Nami urges for compassion,
Zoro understands that the crew must remain
loyal to Luffy.
Zoro also refuses to allow Usopp to join while
deflecting with humor or antics.
He’ll only allow Luffy to let him board
the ship if he issues a genuine apology for
his misdeeds.
Without Zoro’s strength and conviction,
the crew may have fractured permanently on
Water 7.
In the next arc, Thriller Bark, we get the
single most important Zoro moment in the entire
series.
“Nothing Happened.”
When the entirety of the crew is incapacitated,
Kuma strikes a bargain with Zoro.
The warlord will spare Luffy and the rest
of the crew, if Zoro agrees to take on all
of the pain that Luffy suffered during the
battle - on top of Zoro’s own already severe
strain from fighting Ryuma and Oars.
This is the ultimate instance of Zoro shouldering
Luffy’s burdens and acting as a first mate.
And moreover, despite being terribly wounded,
he stands with pride as he declares that “nothing
happened.”
Zoro doesn’t do the things he does for credit.
He has complete satisfaction in knowing that
he’s done his duty.
It’s just the same with becoming the world’s
greatest swordsman.
He’s not doing it to gain clout or recognition
in the world.
He simply wants to prove his strength to himself
and no one else.
During the two year timeskip, Zoro demonstrated
just how loyal he really is to Luffy.
In order to become stronger and help fight
for Luffy’s dream, he sacrificed his pride
and begged for Dracule Mihawk to take him
as a student.
Zoro began as a character who with a single
goal.
He wanted to prove his own strength.
But eventually, he found that through dedication
and loyalty, he could find an even greater
purpose.
By fighting for not only his goal, but for
Luffy’s dream as well, he unlocked true
strength.
Strength enough to become the world’s greatest
swordsman.
CLIMAX
This unbridled power, though, isn’t what
makes Zoro such a beloved character.
It’s not just his bad ass fights - there
are plenty of characters who offer that kind
of action.
Zoro’s real draw is his honor.
His compassion.
His altruism.
When Luffy found him, Zoro hadn’t been crucified
as a test of his own will.
He was doing it to save an innocent little
girl.
And even though Zoro walked a lonely road
in pursuit of his goal, he never truly walked
alone.
His dream was not just his - it was inherited.
Zoro has never really fought only to prove
his strength to himself.
He fights to prove his strength to Kuina.
Through discipline, loyalty, honor, we don’t
just lift up ourselves, but lift up everyone
around us.
The beauty of Zoro’s character is how he
shows that real strength comes from unwavering
dedication to others.
TRANSITION
And there is still so much more detail and
nuance with all of Zoro’s character.
Especially for his character arc with Luffy.
I have a whole video breaking it down in even
more detail right here.